what's up guys
bang bang lunch money time wall street's
trying to get rich we're trying to get
our lunch money right
she got it she didn't even know that i
was doing that don't forget
that she's here our favorite
our favorite is here but lunchbody's not
sponsored by block five block five's got
three products
you can buy and sell crypto you can
deposit crypto take out a us dollar loan
or you can use their interest bearing
account which earns up to eight point
six percent apy
i'm an investor i use the product i'm a
fan you'll be a fan if you sign up for
an account
go to blockbuy.com blockfy.com
pomp and go and get your account
today what's up just a quick aside
this morning he came and woke me up and
i said
please don't talk to me right now
because i just had a dream and i was
really mad at you so i need a minute
and he said that face that's cause i'm
an angel in real life let's go
okay so americans
are creating new businesses during the
pandemic at a moment of
uncertainty americans are rushing to
form new businesses
um applications to start businesses in
the united states are at their highest
level and more than a decade according
to data from the us census bureau
for the week ending in october october
3rd the most recent date available
requests jumped nearly 40 percent from
the same week one year ago
interesting i'm one of those people but
i didn't
file with the sense so if
you lose your job what happens you gotta
go create a job or get a different job
there's another job so what do you do
you go create a job
if there's opportunity there's chaos
there's uncertainty
it all means that businesses get started
we know that one of the best times
in a market cycle to start a business is
at
the bottom at the economic carnage
that's what's happening
doesn't really shouldn't be surprising
to people but it is surprising because
don't you think
that if you are worried about losing or
like
not having a lot of money to pay your
bills etc
the riskiest thing you could do is start
a new business if you haven't saved the
money et cetera
why well if you need to create
revenue for yourself income building a
business
could be a good path but it takes time
it takes time for sure
but also i mean look these aren't
necessarily all businesses that are like
high-flying tech companies that are
gonna go raise venture capital i mean it
could be like a mechanic
shop right what could be that but it
also could literally just be like
hey i'm gonna do social media management
oh
next next softbank's
rajiv misra
the head of softbank's vision fund which
is
the largest venture fund in the world uh
he said
that it is preparing us back in the 2020
milken institute global conference
this fact will be run by vision fund
investment advisors and will include
money from vision fund 2 and outside
investors
they have struggled to raise more money
for the second vision font
after poor performance revision front
one and the pandemic have curved outside
interest
so is a spec just the next natural step
well specs are becoming popular we'll
see what happens
but uh there's definitely a race now
let's get into the public markets and i
think that's what uh
is gonna be pretty interesting as we
watch this happen are there
founders who don't wanna do us back and
why
well there's definitely founders who
don't want to do a spec because the
economics can be really off
um it may not actually be the best path
for them to get there maybe a direct
listing is better maybe a traditional
ipo is better
so it's all you know there's certain
criteria or pros and cons to it if it
makes sense for you you do it if
it doesn't then you don't do it okay
makes sense right
but softbank they got
cannons and cannons and cannons of money
yes why do they want to do a smack
because they're putting some of soft
bank vision to
[ __ ] money in to do it as a way to try
to drive returns
wow sounds interesting um
disney is restructuring its media and
entertainment divisions
in order to further accelerate its
direct to consumer strategy the company
will be centralizing its media business
into a single organization
that will be responsible for content
distribution
welcome finally disney let's go let's
get up let's get the party going
they're a big focus now streaming
netflix has been streaming for the last
decade
but i will say this disney has done a
fantastic job with disney plus
and other things and so this seems like
it's not actually a new strategy all
they're doing is now they're kind of
like
committing more to this strategy they're
doing a re-org they're doing all the
stuff
but they've actually done a pretty good
job i'm somewhat joking when i'm saying
welcome to the party because disney plus
has been
pretty effective yes but a lot of that
was accelerated by the pandemic right
well a hundred they have a hundred
million subscribers and more than half
of those are on disney plus
so 100 million subscribers is a big big
number yep
because ain't nobody watching it's
theatrical
business well they just they have other
issues in terms
of the theme parks got shut down like
you know there's a bunch of other
problems
but streaming is definitely no it's
theme park
it's open somehow but people have to
wear these
masks in this heat so i don't know who's
going to disney
whole other issue okay um ready
yup delta posts another massive
loss has lost more than 11 billion
dollars in the last two quarters
says the recovery could take two years
or more
my eyeballs kind of look fake when i do
that really fake
okay don't don't freak the people out
11 billion dollars in two quarters
just lightened money on fire why
because they still lost 11 billion
dollars even though we handed them
billions of dollars of taxpayer money
and we got no interest and no equity in
the business
we gave them a handout they still
lost 11 billion dollars they are still
going to fire a bunch of people but they
have been particularly challenged
during the pandemic because they
previously relied heavily on business
travel
and international networks two areas
that have been hit
probably the hardest revenue dropped
76
and we gave them a handout and they
still lost 11 billion dollars
that's fine no look businesses lose
money sometimes
okay but the problem is that we had to
give them a handout
because they were bad stewards of
capital and they were bad capital
allocators over the last decade
but they were great for you know
customer service
what airline is good at customer service
actually i'm joking i take that back
okay let's just let's just move on wait
before we move on
yesterday i witnessed the impossible the
unthinkable
the craziest thing i've ever seen we sat
down at a restaurant
he got multiple meats in between two
buns
that were donuts it was a cubano
but there was no bread there were donuts
fried doughnuts
i think that literally that's why i
don't feel well yeah he does not feel
long he has not felt well since that
sandwich
yeah just like my energy got zapped out
of me the fried donuts just
took it out of me i was like can i get a
salad like a caesar plain caesar salad
and they're like sorry we're out of
salad but we have all these donut
options
i was like no i'm good i eat the donut
okay
jeff bezos a space company blue origin
conducted the latest test flight of its
rocket
new shepard at its facility in what in
in west texas
on tuesday the mission did not have
passengers on board
although new shepard launches with a
capsule on top that is designed to carry
as many as six people for a mission
that could be interesting look at all
the billionaires
competing with each other to send us to
space like why are you faisals you're
trying to be popping up in space like
why you don't want us here
think about that no they're trying to
make us a multi-planetary species i
think they're just trying to launch us
out of here so they can have all their
fun well we'll put you on first
yeah then i'll be free all right so what
do you think
new shepherd is designed to carry people
on a ride past the edge of space
with the capsule uh on previous test
flights reaching an altitude of more
than
340 thousand feet so basically this
capsule isn't going on like mars or the
moon or whatever it's just orbiting the
outer edge of
the earth when they say that the edge
past the edge of space yeah don't they
mean past the edge of earth something
like that
so this is all based on the fact that
jeff bezos believes the earth is not
flat
oh my god okay wait what
you're absurd just asking for a friend
go eat your donut
um all right what's next the us army
is testing augmented reality goggles for
dogs
uh basically for combat dogs so the
technology made by a firm called command
site
is managed by the us army research labor
laboratory
military dogs can scout ahead for
explosives and other hazards
hazards but need instructions and the
goggles are designed to let our handlers
direct them
safely out of harm's way this is pretty
cool
if you've never seen military dog
goggles you should google it
just say army dog goggles on google and
it'll send you
photos of these dogs these big ass
things on their heads it's pretty
funny so basically it's not like they
see you know
like uh like very visual things they
just see
little uh directives and little lights
and yeah it gives them the ability to
direct the dog so that the dog can do
stuff but you don't want the dogs to get
hurt
no you don't want the dogs no as
evidenced yesterday when i stood up for
the metaphorical dog
well because usually soldiers direct the
animals with hand signals or laser
pointers
and so if they're too far away you can't
do that so this augmented reality will
allow that to happen honestly
uh ar glasses did not work for humans
but i'm very optimistic about them
working for dogs
okay go ahead with your joke or was that
the joke
no why can pirates never finish the
alphabet
something to do with a plank no
because they always get lost at sea
wait guys the other day that's like like
literally
not even funny guys the other day at
dinner we played a game where he
i like sat like this and he tried to
make me laugh
how long does it take me to wait because
you have a funny face it's not like
i don't have to say anything and i got
her yeah all right guys that's it for
lunch money today we'll see you guys
tomorrow
bang bang hope you guys enjoyed this
episode of lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five so go check them
out there's a link in the description
that you can click on
i'm an investor a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block five is my second favorite thing
in the world behind polena they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to eight point six percent
interest on an interest bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange
i personally use the interest bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find
up to 8.6 interest on a deposit in an
interest bearing account
go do your own research there's risks
associated but 8.6
is pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends